in a meeting last week to discuss
immigration policy we all know this now
president trump referred to haiti and
african countries as [ __ ] countries
now according to witnesses at the
meeting the president singled out the
country of Haiti in particular saying
why do we need more Haitians he's
apparently not a fan of the Haitians so
I have no idea what the president has
against the people of Haiti but as I
said yesterday if the president doesn't
like them they must be lovely people
kind of a compliment
yeah that's why as I've said later this
week actually in just a day or so I'm
gonna fly to Haiti to visit with the
people of Haiti say hello try to make
some friends and show them that
Americans have their back it's going to
be our Konan in Haiti show
I want to go throughout you I find it
personally very strange that President
Trump doesn't like Haiti because if you
look at the country closely Haiti and
Donald Trump have a lot of things in
common really they really do what
thanks Andy sure no problem they do I'll
restate the premise again Haiti and
Trump have a lot in common for example
Haiti was once the largest producer of
sugar Trump is currently the largest
consumer of sugar
true story yeah check this out
90% of Haiti's children are descended
from slaves 80% of Trump's children are
descended from slobs yeah it actually
works
katie is located in the Caribbean and
check this out Trump's money is
laundered in the category Haiti has a
motto
liberté égalité a fraternity Trump has a
motto no fatties so they ain't hot oh
yeah Haiti
gained independence by defeating the
troops of Napoleon yeah Trump gained
pounds by defeating many pints of
Neapolitan ice cream that's just a fact
that was a stretch a fun one yeah it was
a fun stretch some writers broke a sweat
on that one a typical worker for Haiti
makes $2 75 cents a day
a typical worker for Trump still hasn't
been paid
finally Haiti was the first black
Republic in the world and the first
country in the Western Hemisphere to
abolish slavery Trump once took a
picture with Kanye well if you're
interested you can follow my trip to
Haiti in real time I'm gonna leave in
about two days at facebook.com slash
team cocoa instagram.com / team Coco and
twitter.com slash Conan O'Brien none of
this it's just still gibberish to my
parents but I do it anyway
you